plus l'ambiance électrique sur ce
plateau j'hésite presque un an cette
année suggéré torpille job lance
nathalie l'oiseau la tête de liste en
marche aux élections européennes
n'étaient temps en campagne sur l'île de
la réunion hier et dans son emploi du
temps il y avait dimanche 14 avril 5h30
arrivée à l'aéroport de la réunion la
pauvre à une nuit courte et 8h30 messe à
l'église du saint-esprit avec l'adresse
et s'écrit ouvert à la presse alors tout
ça avait réagi un certain nombre de
responsables politiques en particulier
jean luc mélenchon mais voici pour
commencer le point de vue d'elisabeth
board qui est la musique chargée des
transports aletheia sur france 3 est
elle la messe elle n'y va pas je sais
pas exactement dans quelles
circonstances elle a pu faire cet appel
bon je suis moi je pense que c'est
important aussi qu'elle soit dans ses
territoires d'outre-mer
non c'est pas la question mais ça ne
vous choque pas qu un ministre il ya une
à une messe ou une candidate à une messe
personnellement je n'y vais pas et je
pense que voilà il ya aussi les
principes de laïcité dans alors que dans
la vie cela questions posées par notre
confrère est ce que ça vous choque qu'un
responsable politique aille à la messe
mais en tant que personne et peut bien
faire ce qu'il veut le problème c'est
d'y aller en tant que candidat et dans
le cas d'une élection
l'élection à venir européenne et de
manifester en appelant la presse donc en
dérangeant les fidèles qui pourrait
aller à l'église et qui ont peu spéciale
donne envie d'avoir des journalistes
d'ailleurs elle a changé son emploi du
temps pour l'enlever bon entre nous on
d'errements aussi peu dans l'avion
venant immédiatement dans une messe la
plus faire une bonne sieste mais bon je
sais pas si c'est sec c'était ce
dimanche des rameaux est une célébration
importante blessure bien sûr monsieur
mais ça ça dénote ce qu'elle a fait là
ça dénote quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre du 2
que fait macron qui a mené le
communautarisme anglo saxons en france
macron les gens sont moins révolter mais
est allé et à les rompre le ramadan est
allé au dîner de l'iftar avec collomb il
a fait le discours aux évêques discours
aux protestants il va au crif
bref perso moi oui oui mais failli leur
sol par rapport à ce que doit être un
présente de la république française où
les valeurs à défendre son la laïcité
qui permet à chacun de vivre sa religion
comme il veut mais il n'a pas à
l'utiliser or cette façon d'aller voir
les différentes communautés religieuses
et de dire oh je fais des selphy avec la
thèse je fais je joue je joue avec
lequel bondieuseries et ben s'est joué
sur le communautarisme et ça n'est pas
la république française alors êtes vous
étonné que nate et les oiseaux se soit
rendu à une messe ce dimanche à l'île de
la réunion
vous êtes 77% à nous répondre non même
si effectivement le sujet c'est à la
fois qu'elle aille à la messe et aussi
qu'elle en fasse la la promotion et jane
goody il n'y a rien d'étonnant à ce
qu'un responsable politique se rendent à
une messe qui est choquant c'est
qu'elles sont soit excusé pour
satisfaire un électorat
et puis élan qui est plein dans la
pensée qui nous dit nathalie l'oiseau
tente de prendre dès le vote des cathos
à l air pour l'interrogation voilà et
pragma considère qu en temps de campagne
manifester les affinités religieuses
dans un pays laïc et délicat et vous
vous en pensez quoi autres c'est mieux
je pense qu'elle fait bien ce qu'elle
veut
en tant que nathalie l'oiseau personnes
croyante elle va à la messe si elle veut
effectivement ce qui me choque plus
c'est nathalie l'oiseau tête de liste de
la deux pour les européennes qui va à la
messe en convoquant la presse
ça c'est plus c'est plus ces peluches en
convoquant disant ouvert à la presse oui
d'accord ça s'appelle et ça s'appelle
convoqué la presse ramon journalistes
quand il marque est ouvert à la presse
ça veut dire venez donc braves gens donc
donc je sais très bien ce que ça veut
dire même si c'est sibyllin c'est quand
même c'était relativement nets pour tous
les confrères qui ont pu lire cette cet
agenda d'ailleurs c'était sur l'agenda à
la presse elle-même plaide l'erreur
humaine bon bah écoutez elle est dans
une relation et religions de pardon on
peut éventuellement lui lui accorder sa
chirurgie un problème en général avec
les tentatives de récupération
religieuses quelles qu'elles soient
parce que je pense qu'effectivement la
laïcité c'est pas un principe avec
lequel on doit à transiger
parce que ça va très vite trop loin elle
plaide l'erreur humaine mais quand même
elle en remet une louche aujourd'hui sur
son fil twitter en disant en s'adressant
à jean luc mélenchon et en le disant oui
je me suis rendu à la messe pour les
rameaux comme je leur ai fait à paris
faut-il me cacher ou vous demander la
permission
la laïcité c'est la liberté de croire ou
de ne pas croire
si la possibilité de ne pas crier sur
les toits caroline valence il ya
beaucoup de confusion je suis d'accord
avec tout ce vous avez ici dit ici parce
qu'en fait c'est la même chose vous vous
vilipendez le fait qu'elle ait annoncé
qu'elle allait à la messe est pas le
fait qu'il y est allé et avec ça y'a pas
de problème sauf que la question que lui
opposent et j'en ai c'est ça vous choque
pas qu'elles soient liées à la messe un
peu comme si on me disait vous choque
pas qu'elle serait dans un cinéma porno
donc c'est pas le fait qu'il soit allé
en fait c'est le fait qu'elle est
annoncée et donc il ya cette confusion
qui règne en permanence dans les
questions posées dans la mélasse on
parle c'est l'âme c'est le fait de
l'officialiser en france on ne parle pas
aux communautés ont par la nation comme
ça n'était pas pour le climat de
concorde c'est la cour
le lendemain encore entendu le point de
vue de fer canadien je veux pas briser
la concorde
effectivement vous pouvez non mais c'est
vrai que ça en dit long sur la vacuité
des campagnes européennes c'est à dire
que faute d'avoir un débat intelligent
sur les idées sur l'intégration
européenne et bien on en est finalement
inversé dans du marketing identitaire
communautaire en essayant de signer les
son appartenance à telle ou telle
communauté
je pense que les élections européennes
plutôt l'idée européenne mérite mieux
que ça mais là encore je pense qu'il va
falloir attendre pour de véritables
propositions je pense que cette campagne
européenne est complètement ratée c'est
à dire que à quelques semaines du
scrutin
on n'a aucune idée de ce que proposent
les différentes formations politiques on
ne sait même pas comment va se dérouler
le la nomination du président et
commission européenne je doute qu'on va
répliquer le système de 2014 qui
consistait à lier étroitement les
élections les élections parlementaires à
la désignation du présent des
commissions donc là dessus je pense que
ça montre que la campagne européenne
mois les fichus c'est à dire que m'ont
pas plu du tout de l'intégration
européenne
voilà encore commencé vraiment fait oui
à la fois comment il va faire appel ni
de religion des choses qui sont
autorisés juste et bien merci beaucoup à
tous les cadres finalement sur sur cette
ambiance de concorde
on va se quitter on a encore deux heures
et demie et enfin un peu moins
maintenant avant de savoir ce que
prévoit le présent la république que on
écoutera avec attention ces annonces
pour savoir si vous étiez ou non
pression c'est tout pour ce soir pour
point de vue merci beaucoup de votre
attention et bien sûr vous retrouver
marié mais les lombards demain au même
endroit quelque chose me dit qu'on
débriefera l'intervention présidentielle
bonsoir
[Musique]